did you have anxiety or would you call
it depression when you were a kid
I had both I had well no I was like
things started out great like it may
have been hard for my older sisters my
parents hated each other but I was like
pretty much loving life as a kid I was
the youngest I I I just
um
I was had friends I you know and then
something just like well I was a
bedwetter so sleeping at friends houses
was not good except for my three best
friends they were like twin twins and uh
another third
but even then I do remember I wet my I
peed in my sleeping bag on Amy Martin's
floor and I just did not want her
parents to get involved you know so I
woke up a little early but there was
nothing I could do and she knew I was a
bedrider so I flipped the the
um sleeping bag and then when she woke
up I go I peed but I peed up
because like the circle is like up so
you don't have to tell your mom oh my
God I just remembered that that uh
beat up I don't understand I know it's
not a very good line but amongst Pete on
it and then went back in no like I just
like I get shot off and so it didn't hit
the rug at all or anything yeah so you
don't have to tell your mom because it's
I beat up I like the circle I made it so
the circle was up yeah yeah I get it now
okay I loved it I hope you had to
explain it this thoroughly at that time
to everybody you see the liquid the
urine went up not touching in contact
with the floor or the rug
we all know that water or moisture never
works its way down so it stayed there
for the evening but I I was a little bit
happy-go-lucky and then like Depression
hit me
what age I was
just
about 13. yeah
to like 16.
horrible
and then I was uh better again right for
a while
right
and
this is the part the Eternal question is
did you need that period of time to be
creative did you need that
um I've had every therapist in the world
say no you don't need that you didn't
need it and then there's some part of me
that's always
the the the the
self-inflicting part of me that's just
thinking no you that anxiety helped you
or that depression helped you and that's
a bad you know that's a tricky thing to
play with because uh you don't want
anyone thinking I need this because they
don't need it but then there's part of
you that thinks maybe I did need it I
don't know if that's just Catholics that
do that I do think that it's a good
thing to go I'm the sum of all of my
parts and all my experience have brought
me to this place that um is good but I I
don't think it's I don't think it's I
think it's I mean
when Like Comics are like uh well I
don't want to get better because what if
I'm not funny oh but I'm not a good
example of that because I'm not as funny
as I used to be I'm really not but um
you've been a little too happy I think
maybe yeah I'm gonna go outside and
smash your car with a baseball bat no
I'd be fine with it because it's just
stuff
but uh exactly I don't know but but I do
think that and also it is funny because
I remember saying to my therapist once
I was single and I and I go uh
I mean like how am I gonna find someone
that's done this level of work on
themselves and he just like sat politely
and then I went
oh most people don't need this level of
work on themselves and he was like yeah
wow you know have you even seen the same
person for a long time
this guy I've seen for a while a while
but
um I've seen different people like I
remember
remember do you remember when I was your
therapist no but
we have mutual friends that also went to
the same therapist because I'd see them
in the waiting room but there was but
Pamela Connolly
who was on Saturday Night Live one year
I didn't even realize that when I was
seeing her
she's married to Billy Connolly she was
that British woman she was a shrink
Billy Connolly the the great uh Scottish
comedian yeah yeah but then she was like
I wrote a book about Billy I want you to
read it and I was like this is in your
therapy session and I was like I don't
want to read a book I don't know like to
be fair you hadn't ever read a book
before she just wanted you to read one
yeah but it wasn't like about my
it wasn't like what I paid it wasn't
like a book like a a Pema chodron book
it was like she wrote a book about her
celebrity husband like why do I need to
read that well here's the thing I think
it's some people say when you're in
therapy and some therapists believe
you're not supposed to know anything
about the therapist right and their life
so the person I talked to I really know
nothing about her life I know nothing
about it and I just because she has not
revealed anything I never say anything
like well so I won't have a good holiday
and I hope you have a good time with
your family question mark they were
killed in a fire yeah
oh how does that make you feel to know
that about me yeah and what you just
brought up but then I've but in the
course of my years of trying different
people and different methods I've had
other people that tell me everything
and that's kind of weird you know I
think there's a happy medium but that is
true like when I was seeing this Pamela
I um
I remember I loved her and I remember
saying to friends like I mean she's like
my best friend I mean I feel like she's
like my best friend and then like one
session later I I asked her
do you have any kids and she's like I
have five and I was like oh I don't know
her at all I pay her and she's not my
friend I don't I'm a out if she
is I'm an right I still think
you can pay people and then they're
still your friend like Sona I've paid
you to be my friend that's true yeah
that's true I mean that's why this whole
podcast exists so you could have friends
that you don't you don't pay
you just said this whole podcast is a
trick for me to finally get some friends
that aren't in my employee right there
have been times in the past where I've
had I mean especially back in the late
night days when I would have parties and
look around and I employed everybody
yeah and I was having a really good time
and then I realized oh maybe they think
they have to be here no I don't I don't
no no I mean I'm kind of nice but yeah
but yeah I mean I you know I I think you
get close to the people you work with
some people don't like some people just
work with people and go home and then
that's it but you actually because I
think that you genuinely like the people
you work with right
I tried to say something sincere and it
backfired horribly you're so funny I
wanted to talk about this because
people have all these preconceived
notions about like New Hampshire growing
up in New Hampshire well I just hold on
can we just go back to sauna for one
second oh sure
when she said that you have to pay
people to be your friends and that's
what this podcast was it got real silent
it did and I was gonna fill that space I
decided not to let's see where this goes
and now I can feel like her heart is
beating faster because she has like a
guilt pain I'm sweating so much yeah I
am I'm sweating it's crazy uh she's
wearing this uh light purple uh sweater
and I can see it just vibrating with a
heartbeat yeah it makes me it made me
uncomfortable when I said that thinking
it was kind of a joke but then no one
left so I'm like is that is that real no
it was uncomfortable
she's shaking like Amy klobuchar's bangs
during
presidential
well no it's okay I mean I welcome I
welcome truth here on on on the podcast
and maybe
I mean I just thought that that was like
the whole con like the whole conceit of
this podcast you said it Sarah's getting
1200 for being here too I'm sure I mean
but just know I mean you're batting like
600 that's really high
you know that's pretty good yeah I
thought that that was what this whole
podcast was about but that's okay well
it sort of was you know kind of a jokey
title but then it became real in that I
do like what is absolutely true is
you're an exception but there's a bunch
of people because we've hung out and had
real conversations there are a bunch of
people I really admire and and have
loved for years and I had
quick connections with them on a late
night show in front of an audience with
a band and I never really got to talk to
them and that this has been fantastic
because I get to do that yeah but you
and I over the years have hung out I
mean I think it was I think it was the
last time you did the podcast yeah that
was our like awesome bonding day it was
a really nice happening which is we were
in New York and I was taping at earwool
Studios and you came over to do the
podcast and then afterwards we're done
and it was just one of those things
where I think it was winter time I want
to say it was Winter and it's kind of
dark
and you said yeah okay well and I said
so what do you what do you do now and
you said well
I gotta go
um were you doing the comedy seller no
it was like Gotham and we were right
near Gotham and I so I go I have to be
basically here in three hours so I'm
just gonna like walk around you're like
you wanna get somebody yeah and then
um you're never supposed to reveal that
you have nothing on your schedule that's
like rule number one of being powerful
is that true no oh I'm kind of kidding
but I basically said I've got nothing to
do let's hang out together and I said it
just in that tone of voice yeah and then
uh but we ended up walking around we
went to some gray dog yeah what was that
it was it was like three of them so yeah
it's like a chain and it was very
informal like order at the counter sit
down and then we were walking around and
it was funny because people were acting
like we were doing some kind of bit or
something we would get stopped
occasionally by people saying Sarah
Conan what's going on like what are you
shooting no we're just walking around
right like because they don't see the
cameras when you're they're watching a
bit on on TVs yeah they're probably like
oh you're shooting a bit like no we're
just walking down the street you can see
like others we're digesting hot dogs
right now walking around but it was
really fun it was really nice and
between the podcast and then walking
around afterwards I thought that's not a
job you know in a nice way oh it's not
this is not a task I need to perform
this is just absolute fun was that the
first time you two hung out just the two
of you is PALS I don't I think
one-on-one yeah probably yeah probably
one-on-one yeah yeah there was always
some other around somebody harshing or
mellow that's kind of cool it was nice
we were able to like
complain to each other and stuff yes in
a in a I mean that I should have been
wearing a wire because then we could
have released that as Conan walks with
the podcast guest after the podcast
secretly records it and we release that
that's more content secretly kind of a
dick yeah yeah total dick move did you
go it would be called it would be called
dick move with Conan O'Brien oh my God
so good
all right that's it for uh Connor by
needs a friend coming up dick move I
convinced Sarah Silverman that I just
want to go to abompan and get a double
shot uh almond milk latte but really I
bad mouth people in the business and get
her to confess that she hates them too